♪ Free ♪
♪ This is Tea With GaryVee ♪
♪ Might go make a flip, take a risk ♪
- May 4th in the building.
Hello, everybody, good morning.
Good morning, good afternoon if you are
in Europe and beyond.
Good morning, good very
early morning, West Coast.
You know, 6 a.m. crew,
there's a lot of you, I appreciate that.
Super excited to be on the show.
Hope everybody had a tremendous weekend.
And this is Tea With GaryVee.
Dustin's on the ones and twos,
always appreciate my man.
And let's get right into it.
- Hi.
- Hi, Samantha.
- How are you?
- I'm well, how are you?
- Great, thank you.
- Yeah.
- So, my question is,
basically, I'm an artist and a big part
of what I do is web comics.
Web comics mostly about dating,
I've built my audience on
it, I've become known for it.
And while I love creating
that kind of content,
I've been wanting to branch out
and share art about other topics,
like pieces of my life.
But when I do that, my
engagement totally plummets.
So my question is, do I stick with
what I'm known and loved for,
or do I keep experimenting
and branching out?
- Experimenting and
branching out in perpetuity
and making it a bigger
mix of your content.
You know, I basically
completely reset in my career
when I switched from Wine Library TV
to making business videos.
You know, the being a slave to engagement,
is a super sad existence.
- Yeah.
- I mean, even the way you're
asking the question, I'm like.
(Samantha laughs)
For me watching, you know?
You're like, you know?
You know, this is happening to everybody.
It really happens to talented people
that are making creative, like yourself,
it happens to people
that love certain genres,
it happens to people that
grew up as comics or models.
You know, 'cause they evolved.
It happens to every child influencer
that hits because who you are
at nine is very different
than who you are at 16.
Yeah, I think you need
a much healthier mix
with what you wanna put out.
Be okay with the engagement drop
because over a course
of three to five years,
three to six months, you'll notice
that you'll start building an
audience for the other stuff.
I mean, when I first started doing some
of the flipping garage sale
stuff, it didn't do well.
Now it's my most performing content.
Like, my garage sale clips
outperform my business stuff.
You might have noticed, at some point,
if you had followed me
like a year and a half ago,
I just started making cartoons
about the things I believed in.
That wasn't, you know,
that also at first, did okay
and then really got hot,
so you know, I think you
really need to mix in stuff,
including, for example, I see the thing
over your left shoulder,
that kind of design.
Including four of those in a row,
and then just a picture
of you drinking cocoa.
It won't do as well, 'cause
your main audience is there,
but doing as well on
social media can't come
at the expense of who you wanna be.
- Yeah, that makes a lot of sense.
- It's super simple.
I also wanna talk to you about doing
maybe a branded WineText comic with me.
- I would love to.
- Great, hit up Dustin.
- Yeah!
- Let's get it done.
- Absolutely.
- Awesome, have a great day.
- Yeah, nice to meet you.
You too.
- Nice to meet you too, good luck.
- Thanks.
- Yeah, just to build
on that for everybody.
This is a common theme, and I
think you've seen it already,
even in the short time we've
been doing Tea with GaryVee.
People become absolute slaves
to the engagement on social,
to what my fans want.
And there's that classic analogy of
if I give my customers what they wanted,
I would've made a faster
horse instead of a car.
I just really can't believe that,
I really wanna inspire
people to make sure they post
what they wanna post, even
if it doesn't do as well.
Photos with me and
people don't do as well.
Including my family members,
just doesn't do as well.
But I wanna share that, so, share it.
It's only one post.
You know, to put it in a
different way for everybody,
it's just one post.
The algorithm's not
gonna destroy you for it.
It's just one post, no
post is gonna destroy you.
Let's keep it goin', especially
if it's makin' you happy.
- Hey, Gary, how are ya?
- Hey, Johnathan.
I'm well, how are you?
- Good, hey, just getting started here,
I've worked with your team
and made these GaryVee Lego figures.
- Love it.
- And your team is
just so fantastic to work with man,
you've got the best of the best for you.
- Thank you.
- You bet, so, my question
is about side hustles.
I have lots of side hustles.
I'm an entrepreneur
myself, I'm a musician,
I do the flip game, got my
hands in lots of things.
And the question is, how
do you know when there are
too many side hustles,
is there such a thing,
and where do you cut slack?
- To me, once people understand
that happiness is success,
not financial is success, all of a sudden,
this question goes completely away.
- Sure.
- Because people
that have a ton of side hustles
do it 'cause they like it.
You know, eight out of 10.
Two out of 10 think
they're gonna find some
sort of passive income,
scheme that's gonna let
them lie on the beach
and just make money.
But most people that have a
lot of things going on are
just inherently creative
and need the action.
- Absolutely, yeah.
- You know, a lot of people are like,
"Wow! GaryVee, you're so nice,
"you're helping your dad
so much with WineText."
(finger snaps)
Dustin.
You know, super cool, but the
reality is I need WineText
as much as WineText and my dad needs me.
Right? I need that creative outlet,
like we sent out an email this morning
to a big 300,000-person wine list
and I couldn't wait to wake up
and see what the numbers look like.
And so, I really believe that
creative people need a lot
of things and it may not
maximize your financial impact,
it does for me, because
things like WineText allow me
to stay focused on VaynerMedia.
But for some people, they may
never find massive financial success,
but they'll be happy playing
music, flipping stuff,
building Legos, like
happiness, Johnathan, right?
- Sure.
- I think if you can make
one of those things your 80%,
you can then flirt with the 20%
to keep you kind of creatively happy.
You know, maybe 70, maybe 70.
- Absolutely, I had a mentor
that said that exactly, yeah.
- Yeah, maybe 70/30,
but after that, it can
get too spread thin.
There's a great football analogy of
if you have two
quarterbacks, you have none.
There's a great Russian saying
that basically translates
to you can't have you ass on two toilets
at the same time, you know.
So there is the extreme,
this is all balanced,
but I do think 70/30, 80/20,
and for everybody listening,
if your core business is 70% of your time,
80% of your time, I
think you can get away.
I believe that I'm a person
that is better at my 80% thing,
VaynerMedia, because of VaynerSports,
because of WineText, because of Empathy,
because of the K-Swiss
deal, 'cause of GaryVee.
You know, da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da.
So, I think that my 80 acts like 110
instead of my 100 acting like 90.
So, I think for a lot of us,
we need the side hustles to
make our core thing go better.
- Absolutely, yeah.
That's well-said, I love it.
- You got it, brother, take care.
- Awesome, thanks, you too, appreciate it.
Good morning Jess Murphy,
good morning Melissa A.
Jesus Rios, what's good, brother?
Just A, 11 things, Jara
Young, good morning.
Jara Young, I don't see
you signed up for WineText.
And neither are you, Bradley Wood.
Jara Young, Bradley Wood, I need to,
you need to reply right
now with you're signed up
or not signed up, or if you live in one
of those bullshit states
that we can't ship to.
And Dustin's gonna put
you up when you reply.
Let's keep this goin'.
Hey Erick.
- Hey, is this the Dr. GaryVee show?
- It sure is, sir.
- You're gonna give Dr. Phil
a run for his money, I think.
- I appreciate that, thank you, my friend,
how are things?
- I love you, man,
I love you, man. Everything's good.
Here's the deal, here's the question.
How can I turn what is
usually a one-time business
into a lifetime customer?
And here's my business, wedding florist,
family started over a
hundred years ago in Detroit,
my grandfather, first family business,
was built right at the
close of World War II.
Family still owns it, I moved
out to Southern California,
I've been here since 15 years,
most of my business
comes from bridal expos
and my relationship with the venues were,
I've got about 10 venues
that I'm a preferred vendor.
So that's where most of my business comes.
But usually, I see that bride
one time through the course
of maybe six months to a year,
I may hear from a bridesmaid a year later
or a sister to do another
wedding, but then that's it.
So, I'm doing both flowers,
and also, I'm an officiant,
I'm a licensed minister, so I probably do,
like this year already, I've booked,
even with COVID-19, I've
booked about 40 weddings
for this year, this time.
And I have another 10
next year already booked,
and I'll probably do about
two officiant services.
When I meet with the bride,
she needs a minister,
I offer that as a service as well,
and then I probably do
about two to three a month.
But I'd like to somehow see, you know,
once that wedding's over, I
rarely hear from them again.
And I don't know really what service
to offer them, so.
- It's funny,
it's funny you say this.
I've been thinking about
this exact business,
believe it or not.
So you said flowers, right?
- Yes, wedding flowers specialist.
- Makes sense.
You know, I've been thinking
a lot about what the top
of the funnel for acquisition is
for a man buying flowers for his wife,
for Mother's Day,
Valentine's Day, birthday.
And I've always thought, wow,
the wedding industry
really fucked this up.
The flowers people,
obviously, a 10, 15, 20,
30, 40, 50, $100,000 flower execution
at a wedding is very different
than the $300 bouquet.
However.
- Right.
- You know, if you think
of the typical guy,
which is a big audience.
If the person that's doing flowers
for the wedding literally just looked over
at the other person at the
wedding, which is the guy,
which eight out of 10 times, I'm sure is,
six out of 10 times is
not involved intimately
on the flower part, and said,
"Hey buddy, do you wanna
order a subscription from me
"that automatically
sends your wife flowers
"on whatever three or four key occasions?"
There's four times a
year between anniversary,
Valentine's, eventually Mother's Day,
if they go that route, and birthday.
- Yeah.
- I've been fascinated by
leaving that free business
on the table, even if
you took a referral fee
and outsourced it to
somebody who did small things
instead of big things, got it?
- There you go.
- Got it?
Even if you took 50% of the,
if you roll up on any
local florist and said,
"Look, let's split it 50/50,
"I'm gonna bring you the customer.
"You know how much advertising costs,
"I want 50% of the profit."
But I'm there, I'm in
the acquisition place.
I mean, by the way, back
to sisters and things,
I think there's a massive
flower subscription business.
- Wow.
- On the back of florists, and
subscription, not one time.
- Yeah.
- I mean, look, Calvin
Night in the comments,
"This is genius, I just
may do that myself."
Guys don't wanna think about this shit.
- Yeah. (laughs)
I don't.
- We suck.
Yeah, so if you told me four times a year,
you're gonna bang me for 300 bucks,
or if somebody's 50 bucks,
or whatever the number is,
I'm thrilled, that's the greatest,
that's more exciting than fucking wedding!
- Yeah, because now you're a good guy,
your wife's gonna love or
your family's gonna love you,
your mom, whatever, that's great.
- And per normal wedding,
you're probably gonna inevitably,
half the groomsmen, or
the father, or married.
It's not one, I think if
you really play it hard
and don't come off super douchey,
but you come off communicative,
you're probably signing up
three to five subscriptions
at a time.
- Wow.
- You know, that adds up.
You said 40?
- Yeah, I do, right now,
and that's just right now.
I mean, that's just, here we are, April.
And I had that even last
month because of COVID-19,
I've had to reschedule a lot of weddings
so I'm kinda open right now, but yeah.
I should probably double
that by the end of the year.
- I mean, you talk about 80,
you talk about two people on average,
sometimes one, sometimes
zero, sometimes five,
depending on the wedding party
that signed up for that subscription.
Let's just call it 160 people,
four times a year, it's recurring.
You might keep,
you asked me, "How do I keep a customer
"or create a more than one time?"
I'm showing you a way to hit 'em
four times a year in perpetuity.
- That sounds great.
And I like that because
as a floral specialist,
wedding specialist, I'm not
your normal retail store.
So I order flowers, bring
'em to my home studio,
I design everything here, so
I don't always have flowers
in the cooler like a regular retail,
but if I develop a relationship
with a retail business,
that would be awesome.
- Or, Erick,
at scale, you eventually
realize that your,
besides birthdays and wedding,
I mean, there's two times a year
that you could do it yourself.
- Yeah.
- Mother's Day
and Valentine's Day,
you could control that
and keep all the margin.
'Cause once you get to scale
and have a thousand people
on your subscription, now you
have enough scale to buy both,
you see where I'm going?
- Right, as long as it was local,
because I'm from the Southern
California, Temecula area,
'cause a lot of brides,
they'll fly in, right?
They'll do destination weddings.
- Yeah, but honestly, if you're
outsourcing the fulfillment,
you don't need to be local,
what you need to do is
spend a good couple months
on finding 50 to 500
partners to be the execution,
and you keep a margin
on top of the execution,
- Oh, boy.
- See where I'm goin'?
Move it even outside of
the, yeah, I gotcha now.
- Literally, Rick from
Bernardsville, New Jersey,
flies in for that destination wedding,
he's like, "Hey, I'm pumped about this!"
You literally go to Google
and type in Bernardsville
or Sussex County, New Jersey florists,
you call five of 'em, four are
lazy and don't give a fuck,
the fifth one's like, "Hell yeah,
"I'll take the free money!"
You cut the deal and away you go.
All the orders go through you,
so they don't go around you.
- I love it, that's a great idea.
That's great.
- Well listen, you didn't keep
me around for nothing, Erick.
You don't watch this shit for
my looks, I promise you that.
(Erick laughs)
Thank you.
- Hey, I really love you, man.
I love your content,
you're a blessing, brother.
Thank you, man.
- Thank you, my man.
Talk to you soon.
- Take care.
- Bye bye.
- Bye bye, you too.
- Some people just got it like that.
Listen, some people can score
45 in a big playoff game,
some people can sing the
national anthem and make you cry,
other people can come up
with business ideas, like.
(fingers snapping)
Repetition.
It's what happens when you do and think
and live this for fuckin'
37 straight years,
every second of your life.
This is what happens when it's your ethos.
Let's keep it goin'.
- Hey, Gary, how's it goin'?
- I'm well, Benner, how are you?
- I'm doing good.
So, a little about myself,
I spent about 7 years in the military.
- Thank you.
- After, thanks.
And I later transitioned
out, and now I'm going
to college for professional
and technical communications.
I have about three years left.
And a lot of my gears, a lot
of my drive is turning towards
the social media, communications aspect
of what's going on around in the world.
And kind of my question right now is,
how can I become a more respectable
person in that industry?
- Meaning, why do you wanna
be respected, let's play.
'Cause I think you'll see where I'm goin'.
- So, why do I wanna be
respected, because I wanna be able
to work with small clients, large clients,
and also with people that I can help.
I wanna be able to help
others and help people grow.
- You wanna build your business
and you think--
- Exactly, yes.
- So, I think that's right.
I just wanted to hear you say it.
I think the way you do it,
is you do three to five
things and services
and deals for free, in
return for the endorsement
and the reviews on Yelp or Google reviews,
or wherever that may sit.
And I think you only do
it for free with people
that bring you the most
value for their voice.
- Okay.
- Right, so you don't
just do it for somebody
nobody's ever heard of,
'cause Karen from Temecula, you can just,
you know, it's not gonna
drive you through the roof,
so I think doing free work
for people that have clout,
that their endorsement on
your website or your social,
you know, if someone lands
on your social media and the profile says,
"Oprah says Benner's fucking
amazing at Snapchat."
Quote, unquote.
That's gonna fuckin' matter.
- Yeah, I agree, and it's something
that I'm trying to build, of course,
and as you said, I'm
seriously writing this down.
'Cause I have that mindset
that if I don't write it down,
it'll be gone forever.
(Gary laughs)
And I'm also trying
to create a podcast--
- Respect is earned.
- Yes.
- Respect is earned, right?
So like, we have a huge lead
right now for VaynerMedia, why?
Because the person hired
somebody and that person said,
"I worked with Vayner in the
past, and they're awesome."
You know, it's just reps.
The problem is, when you're at zero.
For example, speaking.
You know, my first
speaking gig was paid for,
'cause I didn't even know
it existed, public speaking.
But after that, I did about
eight to 12 to 15 for free,
because I wanted to get the reps.
I paid for my travel.
Everyone's like, "Gary, I wanna
be a motivational speaker."
I'm like, "Well, I'm not
a motivational speaker."
First, I always play that game with them.
But I'm like, "Look if you
wanna be a public speaker,
"one of the best ways to do that is
"to speak for free at first."
Dave Chappelle and Chris Rock
and Eddie Murphy played fuckin' shit clubs
for $2 or free beer or free
'cause he needed the reps.
You know, Taylor Swift played
the fuckin' local thing
at 14 years old for free.
Everyone's like, I just don't understand
how people don't understand this.
Like, "You need to know your worth,
"Don't do shit for free.",
only said by people who
aren't winning. (laughs)
Do some work for free to get the quotes,
to get the reputation.
- Okay.
- Problem is, the most
people that don't wanna do it
for free realize that their
work's not good enough
to create word-of-mouth.
- It's true.
- If you actually believed
you were great, you would
always do shit for free.
I always do shit for free,
'cause I know exactly what
happens after the fact.
- It's true, that's why
we're doing this, right?
- That's right.
Got it?
- Alrighty, thank you.
- Free work, quotes.
- Thank you, Gary, so much.
Listen, if somebody's
willing to pay you, great!
But at first, it's hard.
- Yeah.
- You know, going from
zero to one is hard.
Free is usually the unlock.
It's a dirty word to a lot, not to me.
- Okay, absolutely, Gary,
- All right, bro.
- Thank you so much.
- You got it, bro.
- Alrighty, bye.
- And by the way, for everybody's gonna go
down the free path, if
you just got inspired,
get prepared to get screwed.
You do a bunch of good work for somebody,
and they're like, they
don't like the work,
and they don't give you a quote,
and then you're like, "Fuck!"
Gary fucked me up, I thought
I was gonna get the quote from this.
You have to realize that
one or two quotes makes up
for the six people that fuck you.
For your own business, you
gotta get ready to be fucked.
Look at this deer.
The deer knows.
Deer's eating that shit for free.
Free works.
In nature and in business.
All right, let's keep it goin'.
- Hi Jessica.
- Hey, hey!
- How are you?
- I'm so excited,
marathon after this, just an FYI (laughs)
- Love.
- Hello, hello!
- Hello!
- First, I just wanted
to, can you hear me okay?
- Yeah, I can.
- Okay.
First thing, I just
wanted to say thank you
for everything you do, we
know that the online space is
kind of the wild, wild West.
So, good people that are really bringing,
is A-okay in my book.
- Thank you.
- For my question, it's a little deep,
which is why I wanted to bring it here,
and that is the fact that
I have been in business
for about eight years now.
And I have been, four businesses
in different industries online.
And I keep running into the same issue
where I know.
- Dustin, let's get this reset.
Can't wait to get Jessica
back, she's awesome,
but let's get her reset.
- Full businesses.
- Thank you.
All right, let me say hello
while Dustin gets set up.
Boxy nerd, always good to see you,
thank you for always being here.
Gabrielle Rodriguez,
I appreciate you back.
D Nation, what is good?
Dirty tea, I do like
the dirty tea T-shirt.
I do like that.
Real quick, winetext.com,
today, huge offer, chardonnay.
It is summer season.
If you're on the East Coast,
this weekend was amazing.
Really excited about today.
Big time, big time
chardonnay, white burgundy.
Big time white burgundy, monster score.
Forbes magazine went nuts for it.
It's going to be a big, big,
big, big, big, big, big offer.
A lot of you are not
drinking enough white wine.
And a lot of you have been asking me.
Really, today's wine is because
I'm listening to the streets.
Tons of red wine offerings,
people have been complaining,
that's the only way to put it.
So, monster white wine offering today.
Let's keep it goin'.
Oh, Jess.
- Are we back?
- We're back!
- We're back?
All right!
- We're back.
- So, my--
- Four businesses, four
businesses you always come
into the same place, which is?
- Having a bigger vision,
but at the same time,
it's one of those things that,
to accomplish the vision
is gonna take work
and even if it take five or 10 years,
it puts me in the fear of success with it,
of okay, if it works, now what?
Now I would be close to 40
and I achieved the thing
I put on the pedestal this whole time.
Or the fear of failure, where
if you do this one thing,
doesn't mean it's gonna
work like everything else.
And if you really lean into
that and go forward with it
and it doesn't work, like, holy crap.
So it's like, I don't put--
- So let's, yeah, I got it.
- Pedestal, vision.
- Yeah.
No, actually, you are putting people
on a pedestal, because what you're worried
about is the judgment when it loses.
- Pretty much.
- Yeah, you actually are
putting people on a pedestal.
- So it's like, I find that--
- Do you have a good sense
of who's opinion you most worry about?
Like, who would be like, "Oh, you suck!"
When I say the person who
says, "You're a failure."
or, "You lost.", or, "I'm
disappointed in you."
Who comes up first?
- Probably like parent type of situation,
which is weird, 'cause I do,
I've done everything the opposite
of what I was supposed to
do already, so it's like,
you already kinda just did
your own thing regardless.
- So that's good!
That means you're super close.
That means you just need to
realize you're still there.
Just 'cause you did it
18 things the other way,
this 19th thing is fucking you up.
Listen, I've been very
consistent with this,
and I think you know this.
I'm obsessed with people
falling in love with losing,
pushback, negativity, the dirt.
All of it.
'Cause it works!
Because once you're not,
that means you're not scared.
This is one humongous game of fear.
- But it doesn't show in anything else,
like I lose all the time
in business. (laughs)
It's just normal, you put something out,
you're like, "Oh, try again!"
Like, do something different.
- I had no fear in life, but
I was scared to kiss girls
in junior high and high school.
Like, great!
I'm sure you, things pop
up in lots of places.
I'm with you.
You know, I'm insane in sports.
Like, I punched my
brother, I want to hurt,
literally, literally want to hurt people.
Literally, my hope when I play sports
against people is they become injured.
I'm being really serious
with you, in my brain,
in that moment, in that context,
I desperately want that
person to be hurt in life.
(Jessica laughs)
That is not who I am in real life.
Of course, it doesn't
show up in other places.
We act different in different
circumstances, the end.
There are people that have shit parents
who are then remarkable
parents, vice versa.
You know, people who have
incredible work ethic at work
who can't spend two minutes
putting up a sign in a building.
Of course it doesn't show
up in the other places.
It's exact--
- And I guess I,
I lean on the fact of, you
know exactly what to do
as far as, okay, launch
this podcast, do this,
build the audience, it's
not gonna happen overnight.
And then no matter what, it's like,
lean back to all the things
that are comfortable in building it.
- Judgment.
People worry about judgment.
People put other people's opinions
on pedestals over their own happiness.
- So do the thing.
- (snaps) Because what ends
up happening is regret.
- Mm-hmm.
- And regret sucks shit.
And then lack of accountability,
now you're moping around,
your 60s, 70s, and 80s, and you're bitter.
And you're blaming everybody but yourself.
- Yeah.
- And then parents die
and you're sitting there
for another 25 years and just,
it's just what I don't want for people.
It's a trap.
The number one thing that everybody can do
for their parents and
themselves is to live their life
on their own two feet and
on their own decisions.
- So, would you say my best
option in this is like,
the topics I wanna talk about,
'cause I've trickled them into,
anything that's a personal
brand, I can trickle it in,
'cause it's about mental
health and topics like that.
And they do well, all the signs are there,
as far as leading that way.
- Sorry.
- Yes, Dustin.
Oh, go ahead,
Go ahead, Jess.
- If I.
Oh, I was gonna say, if I
should just throw myself
in the water, so to speak, of just,
you know what, for 30
days, just talk about--
- Yes, yes.
- All the shit
you think people are gonna judge you on,
just to show yourself
that you're not gonna die.
- I was scared to ride a bike
'cause I didn't wanna skin
my knees, and then I did.
I was scared to swim, I didn't
swim until I was like nine
or something like that, and
then I just jumped in the pool
'cause my sisters started
swimming and that was unacceptable
that my younger sister started before me.
Yes, everything's scary until it's not.
- Mm-hmm.
- It's all boogey monsters, it's all fake.
(Jessica laughs)
It's all fuckin' fake.
It's all fake.
- What's that?
- It's all fake, just go do.
- Got it.
- Over and over and over.
- And, question for you,
is there any chance,
I'm in Connecticut, is there
any chance of coming in
and seeing your, shadowing
your marketing team
for the day, and then I'm happy
to do work for another day, 'cause like.
- That's a trade?
- Yeah, exactly.
- Yeah, you don't need to give back,
but you can definitely
hit up Dustin right now
and we'll set up a three, four hour,
yes, you can shadow for the
day once that day comes,
who knows, that might be early next year
when we're back.
- Yeah, whenever.
- But I'm for it, you got it, Jess.
You ask, you get, done.
- Awesome, thank you so much.
- You're welcome.
Big ups, swing for the
ring, appreciate you.
Thanks for being here
with us, Sam Space 81.
Karen Carrington, it
really is true, Karen.
Everything is scary until it's not.
It's just really real.
Let's keep it goin'.
Hey, Megan.
- Hi, Gary.
- How are you?
- Good, good.
First of all, I just wanna say,
thank you so much for
everything you're doing,
I've been listening to you for a while,
you really changed my life,
you bring so much positivity,
so I just, from the bottom of my heart,
I just wanted to say thank you.
I really appreciate everything.
- You're welcome.
- So, let me just give you a
little bit of the background.
I'm an ER physician, but
I'm also a photographer.
I've been doing photography, actually,
since med school, which is ironic.
A little bit.
But it's mostly travel stuff.
I started a travel blog maybe
three or four years ago.
And then over the past two years,
I've had some successes, you know,
I've been part of some galleries,
some shows, things like that.
So it's been great.
But really, when COVID started,
I began to document my
journey as an ER physician
and a photographer on the front lines,
I've been putting it up
on the blog.
- Wow.
And for the first time ever,
I got some traction on my
work, people interested.
People reaching out to me,
bloggers and podcasters
and things like that.
So I'm very grateful for
that, I've been kind of riding
this wave of success.
But my question is really,
I want to reach out more
and kind of present this
project and put it out there,
but my question is, I know you always talk
about bring value, and I
feel as a photographer,
as a creator, sometimes it's
really hard to reach out
and don't look like you're
just pushing your content.
I want to be able to provide
value, but I just don't know
how to do it in terms of other
than the work itself being--
- Well, the work itself is the value.
If you're asking when you're reaching out,
there's a couple ways, it depends on
who you're reaching out to for what.
I mean, you're more than
welcome to reach out
to people you admire and
wanna do business with,
and say, hey, I wanna give you, I wanna,
I'd love to do some photography for free.
Let me know if you're interested,
here's some, check out
my profile for work.
I mean, that's immediate
value that you're bringing.
Now, I get asked 50 to
500 times a day for people
to do free work and 99.9999% of the time,
I say no, 'cause when you're
in a place where people want
to get access or something from you,
they're gonna offer that, and eventually
it doesn't become as valuable.
You know, when DRock
offered to do a free film,
it was super valuable to me.
Now there's 5,000 of those,
it's just supply and demand,
and that's okay.
But there's plenty of people
who will take you up on it.
And I think asking is okay.
Sometimes, people blend my advice,
or it's not, I don't even think
I give advice, to be frank.
It's funny, even the
way that just came out,
I don't like it.
I think people blend my thoughts,
my hypotheses, my opinions,
and think it's absolute every time.
It's actually why I wrote
"Jab, Jab, Jab, Right-Hook".
You know, sometimes, it's okay to ask.
You don't need to blend it every time.
- Sure.
- And the value is the work.
So, and you can always offer
to do some work for free.
- Yeah.
I guess, just, I always wonder,
because I feel like with the
type of photography that I do,
it's more, I don't know if I'd call
it documentary, or whatever.
You know, I always, just felt like it's--
- No, I understand where
you're going with the content.
Like it makes sense to me.
Especially if you're
talking about front line,
or maybe like emotional pictures
of people in moments that capture,
that photography is well-established.
We all know that photography.
I guess the question is, what
would be your dream scenario?
Doing photography full-time
and sustaining your life,
I assume, right?
- I'm not really sure, you know.
I think being a physician
is part of your identity
- I love that.
- After you've been
through so much, so I think in the end,
I do wanna keep doing that.
Before the whole COVID thing started,
I never really blended the two.
- Yeah.
- It was always like,
oh, I could do something
on the side, like workshops
and things like that.
- And now do you think
you can blend the two
in perpetuity, or do you think
this is a moment in time?
- You know, it's funny you ask that,
'cause I started to think about that.
The other day, I was
like, 'cause obviously,
the pandemic is not gonna last forever.
But I did start thinking about it,
I was like, you know, this is something
that I could actually continue doing.
- I think so too.
I think so too.
And you know, just like
firefighters after 9/11,
I think this has been so
much devastation from this,
but one of the great things
is the appreciation level
for nurses and physicians
and doctors will now
never be the same for
next 20 years, minimumly.
There's so much gratitude,
collective gratitude
for the men and women and heroes
that are at the front lines
of this enormously
difficult pandemic, and so,
I think that because of that,
that even gives you more
permission to keep going with this.
I think that if I'm you,
I'm putting out your work everywhere.
So it's not just Instagram.
Do you have a Pinterest account?
Post it there.
Twitter, Facebook, making collages
against popular songs on TikTok.
I think you need to put yourself
in a position the same way
that people are reaching
out to you right now
off of the small exposure base.
You can make one collage
against one epic song
that's popping on TikTok right now,
and it could catch four million
views, the right 13 views,
and then it might give you
the leverage to do it forever.
- I see.
- You've gotta really
strike during this time,
this is the highest emotion
against those photos.
So you need to be
everywhere, and you need to,
like, every photo you took,
I know you're probably
like every other artist,
Oh, this one's not as good,
this one's not as good.
I want all of them out, all of them.
Maybe you saved the best
ones, in your opinion,
for your Instagram feed,
but everywhere else,
Stories, Facebook, Twitter,
every piece of content goes out.
The photo that you think is
mundane might be the photo
that changes your life.
- Yeah, that's exactly
how I see it, actually.
We're very self-critical in general, so.
- Insane.
- Yeah, absolutely.
- All right, good luck.
Bye, Megan.
- Thank you so much, Gary.
- You're welcome.
- I really appreciate it, bye.
- Happy to do it, bye bye.
You know, and that advice is
for everybody, it's universal.
Saying no for the audience
is the greatest mistake
that creators make.
It's their own insecurities manifesting.
I love perfectionists,
"Gary, you don't get it.
I need to be perfect."
You mean you're scared?
Let's keep it goin'.
- Hey, Gary!
- Earnie, what's good?
How are you?
- What's up, man?
I'm good, how are you?
- I'm well.
- Thanks for me having me on the show,
I love the content that
you put out and yeah,
just thanks for everything
that you do for us.
A little bit about--
- Thanks, Coach,
where are you from?
- I'm in Austin, Texas right now.
So, a little backstory,
I have pretty much played at a high level
at basketball my whole life.
Women's basketball.
Played in Oklahoma,
best player in Oklahoma,
McDonald's All-American,
played here at UT,
University of Texas.
- Wow.
- For seven years, seven years overseas.
So, I am trying out, I want to be happy,
I wanna do what makes me happy,
so I would love nothing
more than to build a career
as a skill coach, working with AAU teams,
working with big camps.
- Yep, good for you.
- Being at a new,
be electrotherapist that
helps accelerate injuries
pretty fast, being a speaker
and a mentor to young athletes.
Especially female athletes,
just because I think
I relate to them more.
- Of course!
- But all athletes.
- Yeah, of course!
It's your jam.
- I love 'em.
I'm struggling to figure
out how to build traction.
And brand, I guess, my
sports training business
to get it started.
- I got you, I got you.
It's the same old thing, it's no different
than the gentleman a couple of calls ago.
I think given your relationships,
I'm sure there's teammates
that went on to the WNBA, or
coaches that went to this,
or that and this, you've got a Rolodex.
You know, McDonald's All-American,
you've got relationships.
You've got relationships.
I think, again, I think
you go and document,
once we get back to some normalcy.
I think you hit up every
fuckin' person you know
and you offer your services
for free at a camp,
or minimum wage, or be an intern.
- Okay.
- You being an intern at,
at the Connecticut coach's,
Geno's camp, right?
Let's say he has a
camp, I don't know, but.
You being an intern there and,
you would pay him, in my
mind, you should pay him
for the ability to make all that content,
that's cosigning against the
best program in the nation,
which you then post everywhere,
just like the last woman.
You know how this works, one high,
and especially off the devastating tragedy
of Gigi and Kobe's passing,
like there's so much more attention
to young women's basketball
right now, right?
- Right.
- And just like,
all you need is one, one
high net worth individual
to hire you, to have you
train their daughter,
to wanna start a business with you.
This is all about content
across all the platforms
that leads to business development.
You are one epic TikTok video
away from everything you want.
Yet I say it every morning,
every afternoon, every evening.
And when you're so lucky
to have something like basketball skills,
which is so visual for
the world we now live in.
The shit I do is not visual,
I have to articulate it.
You know, business
operations isn't visual.
- Right.
- You know, making a full-court shot
that gets 40 million
views on TikTok is real.
(Earnie chuckles)
You're gifted, you have the best platform
off the most cultural thing,
basketball, women's, like Jesus!
You couldn't have picked
a better time to be alive,
I just need you to put out
40 pieces of content a day.
- Right.
And 99.99999999999999999%
of people aren't even close.
They just can't get there.
- Okay.
- But it will lead to everything you want.
- You put your email,
you put your email in all your accounts
and shit will just happen
if you make 40 to 50 fuckin'
videos and pictures a day.
Three for TikTok, three
main posts, four main posts
on Instagram, thirteen
Stories, five tweets.
Like, this is real shit, coach.
- Okay.
- You know what's so funny?
I love talking to coaches and
people that know their craft.
You know, inevitably, a niece or somebody
that you know is gonna be
11 and is gonna be like,
"I'm gonna be in the WNBA.",
and you know she's fuckin' not workin'.
- Mm-hmm.
- You know she's not at,
you already know she's finished.
- Right. (laughs)
- That's how I view this with content.
- Okay.
- It's simple.
My little guy loves basketball,
he's about to turn eight.
All I'm doing is making him
work with his left hand.
And I know that's gonna pay dividends.
I also know his genetics aren't
sending him anywhere close
to the NBA, but he's
gonna hurt some people
and pick up basketball
and he's gonna be happy
that left was developed, that's the work.
- Yeah.
- The Euro step that he does perfectly,
which just blows my mind, is the work.
- Mm-hmm, okay.
- You need to do the work on the content,
you're literally one piece of content away
from everything you want to happen.
- Okay.
- It's real.
So you gotta make content about, here's,
everything you know.
Number one mistake with the
way people hold the basketball.
50 different pieces of content
about left hands for righties, 50!
Like, if you got a daughter
that you want to be in the WNBA,
and she's three, and you're
not tying her right hand
behind her back, you fucked up.
That's the video that could change
your life, you understand?
- Yeah, definitely.
- Hundred,
500 free throws a day.
What?
500 free throws a day
and then you go outside,
set up your phone, you
don't want the DRock,
and take 500 fuckin' free
throws, and then you come home,
and you Google how do I edit a video,
and then you fuckin' speed it up
so it doesn't take fuckin' forever,
'cause 500's gonna take a minute.
And now you got a video
of you putting 500 fuckin' free throws
for two minutes and 30 seconds
against a Roddy Ricch song
that fuckin' goes.
- Okay.
- The work.
- Yeah.
- You know, 90% of the
people don't post the content
that I want because they're insecure
and they're worried about judgment.
But another 90% overlaid over that,
not in addition, 'cause there's
only 100%, they don't do it
'cause they don't actually
wanna put in the work.
It's fuckin' work.
- I think it's the fear for me,
like for the last couple years,
I've been on and off with the content
and thinking about it too much.
- Too much.
- And I'm to the point where I'm like,
whatever, I just wanna be
consistent and put it out
and stop worrying about what people think.
- Correct, who cares if
you have four followers,
who cares that you got one like.
We all did at first.
- Yeah.
- And when they come at you, you're like,
"What did you do? Fuck you, like, what?"
What's your handle, because
a lot of people are asking,
what's your handle?
- @ehoopsperformance.
So E-H--
- EHoops.
- Yep, EHoops, kinda like the shirt there.
- Mm-hmm.
- Ehoopsperformance on Instagram.
- YouTube, at Coach Earnie Williams.
- Have you thought
about Coach Earnie Williams for Instagram?
- No.
- I think people relate more with humans.
- Okay.
- I'd rather you, I think
you should change it to you,
and then just put the
@hoopsperformance in your bio,
so it's link-out-able.
I think that will be a better structure,
people connect more with humans.
I believe that high net worth woman, man,
is gonna hire you or
give you that break more
because it's you the human,
than E Hoops Performance.
- Okay, yeah, that makes sense.
- And the other thing that lets you do is
it lets you make a video
of you having a Slurpee.
And then telling the
kids, "Yo! You don't have
"to fuckin' be perfect every minute.
"This fuckin' little
slushie fuckin' helped me,
'cause it gave me."
- Yeah.
- You know what I mean?
It lets you be more human.
- Okay, I like that. thank you.
- It opens up more content.
You're welcome.
- Okay.
- Good luck.
- Thanks, Gary.
Thank you so much.
- TikTok, Earnie, TikTok.
I'm telling you.
- How?
How would you suggest to
put content on TikTok?
- Go on TikTok, type in
basketball in search,
watch 550 videos over two
hours, and start making content.
- Okay.
- It fuckin' kills on TikTok.
- I will do it, I'll do it.
- And do some women empowerment shit,
like get one of your
brother's best friends,
a guy, and play him one-on-one
and fuckin' destroy him,
chop up that video, and
like, that shit will kill.
- That's what's gonna hit. (laughs)
- Earnie, people don't get how much,
guys are delusional,
guys are fuckin' stupid.
Guys don't realize
they can't beat a fuckin'
McDonald's All-American
in one-on-one, they think they can,
'cause they're on that
bullshit guy/girl things,
you would fuckin' destroy
every friend I've got,
you know what I mean?
Put that shit out.
- Yeah, okay.
- That will get women's,
like that's the fuckin'
good shit, you know?
- Okay, yeah.
- All right.
- Thank you, Gary.
- You got it.
Man, some good stuff.
I think that helped a lot of people.
That is nichey to her, but I think a lot
of you needed to hear that.
Let's keep it goin'.
- Hey, Gary!
- Hi, Ginger.
- How are you?
- I'm well, how are you?
- Super nervous, because.
- Don't be.
- Obviously, I'm a huge fan,
and I'm all over your social media.
Huge supporter, and I just
can't thank you enough,
I love your team, I love your community,
your Twitter community, big
ups to everybody on Twitter!
- I love it.
- (laughs) I am, so my
question, first, is,
how do I go deeper but
also wider on my Instagram
after already experiencing some success.
Can you hear me okay?
- Very well.
- Okay.
- My ear just itched.
So, long story, backstory.
So I do pharmaceutical sales by day
and I've been doing it
for a very long time.
I have done more cold calls
than anybody on Earth.
(Gary laughs)
I'm convinced, I really
love talking to people,
and so, six years ago, I
decided, I had a child,
I was like, "You know what?
"I'm gonna pick up a camera,
I'm gonna learn photography."
It became very simple for me,
or very basic, just learning
how to use a camera.
I started doing it every single day,
I became obsessed with my craft.
I learned how to do it very well.
Long story short, got into kids fashion.
Started blogging for a magazine
and started just getting noticed,
and it felt really good.
It's like, wow, I'm
doing good in my craft.
And eventually, that helped me learn how
to study what people want and study brands
and really zone in on how to
attention hack, basically,
which is great, right?
So, I've been doing that,
but I don't know how to
kind of build on that.
- Meaning, how do you define building?
More attention hacking so
you get more awareness,
or convert it into something?
How do you define build?
- I wanna convert it into something.
- But what do you wanna sell?
- That's the thing, I don't know.
I don't wanna--
- Well, good, so don't!
Don't sell, yeah, don't sell.
- I'm happy.
- Yeah, don't sell until
you have something to sell.
- Yeah.
I'm honestly really happy
with what I'm doing,
I love, again, I love the
community, I love the people.
I'm obsessed with connecting and--
- I see it, I see it in
my Twitter, I see it.
- Yeah.
- That's good, me too.
I had a wine store that I was focused on
when I was building my
six years of connecting,
asking for nothing.
First time, it took me years
before there was anything
I asked for, and that was an
$11 book called "Crush It!",
which, oh, by the way,
fuckin' changed unlimited people's lives
'cause they learn from reading, unlike me.
And so.
- Yeah.
- You know this, 'cause we engage so much,
I'm super proud of WineText,
it's literally the best way
to buy wine in America, I
really genuinely believe that.
It's super fun when you have
something to sell, you know?
- Yeah.
- Like, Empathy Wines is
literally the best $20 wine,
I really believe that.
I really feel great about that.
- Yeah, and there's no
pressure because you don't,
like, where I'm at, I'm having,
I'm honestly having so much fun
because it's almost like a challenge.
Like, okay, who can I hack?
And I have to say it,
but when last year,
Will Smith reposted one of my photos,
which I was blown away,
'cause who does that?
- Super cool.
Even you, you reposted one
of my photos and it's just,
the validation of just,
and it's not about feeling like, oh--
- Ginger, Ginger, you're a salesperson.
- Yeah.
- You love the game.
- I do.
- That's amazing, me too.
Do you understand how happy
I get when I find a $12 mug
at a garage sale for 25 cents?
It's more exciting for me
than landing a $5 million deal
for VaynerMedia, I swear
on the Jets, my children,
and everything that I hold,
my chemicals are more excited.
- Yeah.
- You like the idea of strategy of
how am I gonna get Will
Smith and Gary to retweet,
you like that, there's
nothing wrong with that.
That's amazing, you love your process!
It's probably why you're so successful
at pharmaceutical sales.
You love your process.
- Yeah, I do.
- I don't think you have to
have a right hook from social,
I also think you're an
extremely young woman
who may decide to start a
raspberry farm in 17 years
and then that's what it converts into.
- Yeah, well, you're nine
months older than me,
so technically, I'm just
making you my brother,
and we both have twins.
Or we both have dimples.
- Double dimples.
- I'm part of the family.
- Listen to me.
- You can't get rid of me.
- Ginger, listen to me.
Listen to me.
We're extremely young.
- Yeah.
- In 17 years, we're fuckin' 61,
I just, I don't know how
people don't understand that.
I'm gonna be fuckin'
hustling my face off at 78.
I'm gonna be making empires at 70.
I'm gonna win Super Bowls.
I'm gonna be buying countries
and changing the name.
I'm fuckin' going for it,
what are we doing here?
- I know.
And I wanna encourage people, you know,
when you're scrolling on social media
and you kind of just see the same,
I want more, I don't
wanna just post my work--
- So take more.
- And be like, oh, here,
this is what I did,
because I feel like I'm excluding people.
I don't want people to feel like,
oh, look what she did and
how am I gonna supposed
to live up to that?
I had no, I worked from the bottom up--
- Ginger, Ginger, Ginger, Ginger,
don't even take yourself that serious.
- Okay.
- Yeah, humility is the unlock here.
Good news, nobody's
thinking that about you.
When you realize you're the most special,
and you're not special at
all, shit gets really good.
- Yeah.
- Don't let your ego
have that convo with you.
- You're right.
- Nobody gives a fuck about you, Ginger.
- You're right, no, you're right.
- Seriously.
- I've been feeling that.
- The fuck?
- And that's the freedom,
that's where it takes you.
Once you realize that.
- 100%!
Don't have that convo
with you, live up to you.
It's a piece of cake for millions
and it's impossible for other millions.
- Yeah.
- Do you understand?
- Don't go into that game.
- So, I mean--
- Ginger, I think I'm gonna
win the whole fuckin' thing,
and I still know that nobody gives a fuck.
- Yeah.
I know, I'm with you.
- Okay?
So good news.
- And I have
that sense of knowing as well,
there's something deep down there,
and I wanna drag it out, and I don't,
and I'm happy.
- Process, process.
- Patience, just keep going,
just keep experimenting,
just keep putting myself out
there and seeing where it--
- What ends up happening, Ginger,
if we have a lot of
similarities, I think we do,
you start becoming better at giving.
- Yeah.
- I need this hour every morning.
I got a lot of shit going on.
- Yeah.
- But I've gotten to practice of giving,
so I need to do this.
You know, it just becomes your,
it almost becomes like brushing your teeth
and taking a shower.
- Yeah, second nature.
Yeah, it's a part of you.
- Second nature, mm-hmm.
- That's how I feel too.
- Yeah, I mean, it's super fun
to realize you're doing something well.
And people are, you know,
when you came on here,
a ton of people in the
community were like, "Yay!"
- Yay!
- But just remember, if
you ground yourself in
that one little insight to
how are you gonna live up
to it, you're misplaying that.
You're listening to a
couple people's feedback
and more importantly,
you're allowing yourself
to put yourself on a pedestal
and that becomes a vulnerability.
- Yeah.
I put a lot of pressure on myself,
I think I try to build on
where I've gotten myself,
and then I'm like, well okay, now--
- Ginger, you're at your best
when you like the process.
- Yeah.
- You just are lucky, the way I'm lucky,
and there's nothing else to say than luck,
that the process of making the deal
or closing the thing
is the process we like,
a lot of people hate that process.
So our process happens to have
financial success behind it.
But that's a very different
thing than happiness.
- Yeah.
- And so you need to realize,
it is that process that you love,
and then that puts you
in a really good spot.
- My process is, I've found
a love for promoting people,
I call myself a connector,
because I have found the most success is
when I connect with someone that connects
to somebody else, and when
I put them both together,
not by my doing, but because
of, like you call, serendipity.
Things happen, magic happens.
- Of course!
- Get in there.
- Good leads to good.
Bad leads to bad.
- Yeah.
- People in this comments
section right now,
some of them are really good,
and good things will happen.
- Yeah.
- Some of them are
not as good, and bad things will happen.
Life is simple.
- Yeah.
- Like super fuckin' simple.
- It's all about the heart.
- Cynicism, anger,
negativity, has, at times,
short-term success,
which always falls apart
like a cheap fuckin' chair.
It's hard to be good and
optimistic and positive.
- It is.
- It's easy, it's easy to be
cynical and negative and dark.
That's a piece of fuckin' cake.
- Mm-hmm.
- That person's soft, simple, soft.
You're fuckin' soft.
It's hard to be good.
- Yeah, it is.
- Cool, see ya!
- But I appreciate it,
thank you so much.
- You got it.
- Take care.
- You take care.
Dustin!
- Yes sir.
- Let's do some PSAs, there's
a lot of new people in here.
One, if you wanna get on the show,
it is best to sign up
for my text community
where we're sending
out all sorts of stuff.
If you're watching right
now in the US and Canada,
please hit up 212-931-5731.
If you send in your question
with #teawithgaryvee,
but all of you should be
signing up for this anyway.
That's big, so for
everybody that's new today,
Dan, actually everyone in the comments,
reply right now with the number
of days you've been watching this.
Obviously, it's been going
on for about a month or so,
so some of you may not recall.
It's gone on for longer than a month?
Dustin, how long we been doing this?
- March 23rd.
- Mm-hmm.
- First day.
- Reply with how many
days you've been watching,
'cause I saw, yeah, Eddie, Eddie
Claros, one day, love that.
Darnell, day two.
COVID-19 Philly with a bag,
23 days, I appreciate that.
Real Chef Mikey, I've
watched for last three weeks,
texted 90 times.
Mike, you are tryin', bro.
You really are trying.
The other way to get your question on is
to use the hashtag #teawithgaryvee
in Twitter, for all the
international people.
Dustin, tell the team
we want some international love tomorrow.
- International.
- And for everybody
who's watching right now,
screenshoot this, share it on Twitter.
Gary V-E-E is my handle there.
Always gives you a
better change of catching
our attention when you
screenshoot the show.
That's what's goin' on.
Good show today, Dust.
- Mm, everyone loved the florist one.
That idea.
- Yeah.
- Dustin, you have the luxury
of now being around me,
the ability for me to go into
idea to phase is so heavy.
(Dustin chuckles)
We need to do a little bit, yeah,
I wonder if I should do a whole show
just on rapid-fire, tell me the business,
tell me what you want to happen,
'cause that's what, you know,
my two core strengths are mindset,
just optimism, positivity, practicality,
everything in the brain.
But then I also have
actual business strategies,
which, you know, tend to come out less
because of the nature of the format,
which is why I always tell people,
"Watch what I do, not what I say."
It's very easy for me
to give the 40 pieces
of content advice, you know?
So, anyway.
What else, Dus?
You had a good weekend?
- Yep.
- Good?
- Just worked. (laughs)
And then, oh, I did a couple,
people have been hitting
me up to do their podcasts,
so I've been doing that for them too.
- I love that.
- That was cool.
- I'm sure you're busy as shit with that.
(Dustin laughs)
Good, man, hope you have a good weekend.
All right, everybody,
thank you so much for--
- You too.
- Good week, excuse me.
Everybody, thank you so much for watching,
we'll be back tomorrow, I'm
really looking forward to it.
Please share the show, I feel like a lot
of people could get a
lot of value from this.
I've noticed in the comments,
a lot of people talking about,
thank you Scott Jensen,
first time watching.
Jennifer Dalton, thank you so much.
I think a lot of people
are getting value from this
and I think a lot of
people don't know about it.
I think a lot of people
in your community don't know about it.
in your community don't
necessarily love me
'cause I'm too aggressive
in a single video
that they saw on Instagram or
said something about college,
and that got their feelings hurt.
But I would love if you
could share this screenshot.
Facebook groups, Facebook,
your email lists,
your social media, would
mean the world to me.
Gonna do a really fun campaign
tomorrow where if people,
Yes, Dustin.
- Since your All In Challenge is over,
should I not play that
video, I don't know--
- Yeah, don't play that video, it's over.
I think we announce the winner today.
- Oh, okay, cool.
- It's gonna be really cool,
I can't wait to see who won.
Somebody paid 10 bucks for all that.
(Dustin laughs)
Dustin, $10.
- That'll be crazy.
- I think we raised almost
a half a million dollars.
That's amazing.
- In a really short time.
- Yeah, it's really cool.
How much is the All In Challenge up to?
Let's see where All In Challenge is.
We have raised $31 million dollars.
It's crazy.
I appreciate all of you so much.
Appreciate all of the support.
Thank you, Jy, the florist
idea was a good one.
Thank you for donating to the
All In Challenge, everybody.
And thank you to everybody
that signed up for WineText.
I'm really excited about
it, I'm really enjoying it.
Today's offer is really gangster.
Like legit, legit shit, so.
Thank you so much, and
we will talk to you soon.
If you signed up for WineText right now,
I've got like two minutes
before my next meeting,
hit me up with the
confirmation screen on Twitter.
I'd like to follow and retweet you.
Thanks for watching, guys, take care.